عمر ابو لبده صانع محتوى سوري بس محتوى من
اللي كل الناس يمكن بتحبه وما في خلاف
عليه ببساطه لانه عمر شاف ومين ما بحب
الاكل يعني لكن لازم نعطي كل شيء حقه
ونقول انه في وقت صار فيه كثير شافات من
نجوم وصانعي المحتوى عمر متميز ومختلف
وبحسابات ما عنوانها دائما من سوريا لكل
العالم من هنا بدات تغيير عمر بيقدم محتوى
بيسميه ثوره في عالم الطبخ العربي وبرامج
الطبخ التقليديه
جربت شاورما تبعها تايو لواء اسكندرون
والله شكلك مجربه
تاخذ هاي
[موسيقى]
من قبل محاشي على طريقه مرتي فقررنا انه
لازم نعمل محاشي على طريقه امي يعني تمام
له له له له له
تاخد اللقمه يا غالي وبتحضرها بصوابعك شو
بتساوي
صباح الخير
فقع اسرع كبه بالعالم ممكن جربوها بحياتكم
سنه بصل
لحمه ملح وفلفل اسود وقرفه وشويه جوزه
الطيب واذا امرنا بالليل
انا شويب الجديد والمميز والمحتوى المختلف
ساعد عمر انه يصير واحد من اهم شيفات
العالم العربي على السوشيال ميديا حساباته
ما شاء الله عليها ملايين المتابعين ان
كان من فيسبوك الي عليه 7 مليون متابع
تقريبا اليوتيوب اللي عليه مليونين و600
الف مشترك واكثر من 273 مليون مشاهده اما
انستغرام
عليه ثلاثه مليون لايك تقريبا والنجاح ما
شاء الله منورنا
الان لما قلت لك كده الارقام لما استعرضت
الارقام ايش حسيت كثير
خلينا نقول انه
المشاهدات كلها كانت صفر صفر صفر صفر ايش
كان احساسك انا كنت عم بعمل شيء بحبه يعني
الاكل
ما كنت كثير مهتم للموضوع لكن شوي شوي شوي
شوي صار خلاص لازم يكون في شيء افضل من
هيك
بتشتغل على حالي اكثر واكثر واكثر حتى
اليوم من الايام تغير كل شيء وبعدين
خلاص صار في المتابعين والكلام ده كله
وصلت
بتتصاحب مدرسه خاصه ايش المدرسه خاصه هذه
مدرسه البساطه يعني انا مو بس انه بدخل
كمان ان نكتب يقلوا الطبخ لحتى البساطه
يعني بسهلك الموضوع بمسك هي اهم شغله انه
الشيف يعطي المتفررش طاقه ايجابيه يعني
لكن ناس بتقول لك انا لما بشوفك او
بشوفوني لان ما بشوفك بحس بده يفوت على
المطبخ بسوي اكل بده يطبخ بتحمم
مختلف بهارات مختلفه تركيبه مختلف
الطعامات
وكده كثير
ناس بيحبوا انه مثلا
ناجحين بهذا الشكل واهتمام كبير بهم حتى
على التيك توك حتى على الانستغرام
كانه ظاهره هلا هي مو ظاهره هلا شوفي
الوصفات القصيره
يعني الفيديوهات القصيره انا من النهايه
ما بعتبرها وصفه يعني انا بساوي هلا
فيديوهات قصيره لكن يعني هي مالها وصفي
النيه بالميه الوصفه لازم بدها شرح بدي
تفاصيل بده يكون في دقه يعني انه هاي لازم
هيك لازم هيك لكن بطريقه مبسطه لا توصل
للشخص دائما لما يطلع الشيف ويعطيكي
مكونات
وتكون المكونات صعبه خلاص انت بتطلعي من
الفيديو طيبه
[ضحك]
انك محاط اصلا بعائله فيها طباخين ممتازين
يعني الوالده طباخه وزوجتك ايضا برضو
طباخه بس مين احسن احد فيكم
همم كشغل بطريقه صحيحه وعلميه اكيد انا
لانه انا درست هذا الشيء يعني هذا اختلافي
عن والدتي مثلا والدتي تعلمت من والدتها
والدتها تعلمت من 60 وهيك يعني بجره
العاده لكن انا يعني غير الشيء اللي اخذته
من انا وهو صغير مكنته بيشيل علمي دائما
يشيل علمي لازم يكون موجود
حتى في فيديوهاتك على فكره بتتكلم عنه
اكثر من مره بتعلق انه لا يا جماعه انا
دارس هذا الشيء وانه انا دارس وكان في
دروس نظريه وبعدين دروس عمليه وما الى ذلك
بس كاني حسيت انك انت بتحس انه الشخص اللي
دارس اكيد افضل واشطر من الشخص اللي
مودارس
تدفع انا لازم اعطيهم جواب مقابل هذا
الشيء هلا هو ما في داعي يعطي جواب اللي
شايف اللي بيعرف من لما بيشوفني شو عم
بحكي مثلا معلومه انه كيف صدر الدجاج
ينطبخ
الستات البيوت
بدون ما اغطي الطنجره فهي يعني هي النقطه
جدا
انك تدرسيها يعني كثير قصص يعني بحر الطبخ
مين بيني وبين مين يعني
في البيت
[ضحك]
عندها شغلات كثير طيبه وزوجتي كمان تعمل
اكلات يعني مثلا زي شو بتعمل اليبرق
ومحاشي بيطلع معك كثير طيب طيب
ان شاء الله عليك
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
كان معنا الشيف عمر شكرا لك
[موسيقى]